bienvenue dans un monde
merveilleux et si vos rêves devenaient
réalité la légende du restaurant des
avis bonjour il y a quelqu'un notre
patron est un véritable artiste ma
cuisine éittincelante et
futuriste TR
étoiles je suis riche
[Musique]
non mais d' tu sors toi j'ai besoin de
retrouver ma maman tu compes pas garder
laamine qui peut nous AER ai à atindreil
des AB c'est l'entre desculus il
mèneront à la fortune et toi ta
[Musique]
maman plong dans une grande
aventure cette salet fantôme rouge il
est derrière le HBL le fantôme rouge
adore chasser les petites filles tristes
alors souris tu as besoin d'un petit
reling un voyage au000
émotions c'est trop
dangereux tu dois aller jusqu'au bout de
ta quête retenez votre souffle Monon
fier équipage tous à vos
poes lâche ce bonbon Tu veux
bien la vie n'est-elle pas une
aventure il ne faut pas passer à côté le
royaume des Abys au cinéma le 21
février